the term dissolution refers to the
dissolving of one substance in a solvent
the dissolved substance is now called a
solute and the solute plus the solvent
form a solution if the standard change
in free energy delta g naught is less
than zero the dissolution is
thermodynamically favorable
so if we were to put this substance in a
solvent like water the substance would
dissolve and it would form a solution
however if delta g naught is greater
than zero the dissolution is
thermodynamically unfavorable so if we
tried to dissolve the substance in water
it wouldn't dissolve and therefore we
would just see it on the bottom of the
beaker
since we're talking about potentially
making a solution sometimes you see a
subscript s-o-l-n written next to delta
g naught so this would be delta g naught
of solution
we could also call this the free energy
of dissolution we can calculate delta g
naught of solution by taking the
standard change in enthalpy of the
solution and from that subtracting the
absolute temperature times the standard
change in entropy of the solution so
let's look at more detail at what
determines the signs for delta h naught
and delta s naught
we can think about the dissolution of a
solid in three hypothetical steps the
first step involves breaking up the
solid let's think about the change in
enthalpy delta h1 for this first step
solids are held together by attractive
forces for example if we had an ionic
solid it would be ionic bonds or
electrostatic interactions holding
together the opposite charges so if our
goal is to pull apart or break apart the
solid it would take energy to overcome
these attractive forces therefore delta
h1 would be positive
next let's think about the change in
entropy delta s1 for the first step when
the solid is broken up the particles
have a greater number of possible
positions and an increased number of
possible positions means an increase in
the number of possible microstates and
increase the number of microstates means
an increase in entropy therefore
breaking up the solid means an increase
in entropy and delta s1 will be positive
step two is the preparation of the
solvent to receive the solute and let's
think about the change in enthalpy for
this second step
the solvent particles are held together
by intermolecular forces for water
molecules the most important
intermolecular force is hydrogen bonding
the goal of this theoretical second step
is to break apart the solvent particles
and to move them far apart from each
other so there's enough room to fit in a
solute particle since it takes energy to
overcome the intermolecular forces
holding the solvent particles together
delta h2 is positive
next let's think about the change in
entropy delta s2 for this second step
when the water molecules are pulled
apart there's an increase in the number
of possible positions of the water
molecules
and like the first step an increase in
the number of possible positions means
an increase in the number of microstates
which means an increase in entropy
therefore delta s2 is positive
the third step is called solvation which
refers to the interaction of the solute
and the solvent so imagine there's an
attractive force between this white
solute particle and these four blue
solvent particles
if the solvent is water this process is
called hydration and if we think about
say a positive cation interacting with
water since opposite charges attract the
positive cation is attracted to the
negative end of the water molecule
since we have a positively charged ion
interacting with water which is a polar
molecule with a dipole moment this type
of interaction is called an ion dipole
interaction and let's think about the
change in enthalpy for this third step
when the solute comes together with the
solvent energy is released therefore
delta h3 is negative one way to think
about why this is negative is to
consider the ion-dipole interactions on
the right since it would take energy to
break these ion-dipole interactions when
those ion-dipole interactions form
energy must be given off
next let's think about the change in
entropy delta s3 for the third step
because the water molecules are
attracted to the ions in solution the
water molecules have a decreased freedom
of movement and therefore there are
fewer positions possible for the water
molecules a decrease in the number of
possible positions means a decrease in
the number of microstates which means a
decrease in entropy therefore for the
third step delta s3 is negative
now that we've talked about the signs
for delta h and delta s for each of the
three steps let's think about how they
influence the overall changes in delta h
naught of solution and delta s naught of
solution
and let's start with delta h naught of
solution which is equal to the sum of
the changes in enthalpy for the three
steps so delta h1 plus delta h2 plus
delta h3 we've already seen that delta
h1 is positive delta h2 is positive and
delta h3 is negative
so adding delta h1 and delta h2 together
gives us a positive value and since
we're adding a negative in delta h3 it's
the magnitude of delta h3 that
determines if the overall delta h naught
of solution is positive or negative
if the magnitude of delta h 1 plus delta
h 2 is greater than the magnitude of
delta h 3 delta h naught of solution
will be positive
however if the magnitude of delta h 3 is
greater than the magnitude of delta h 1
plus delta h 2 delta h naught of
solution will be negative
therefore it's possible for delta h
naught of solution to be positive or
negative depending on the substance
being dissolved an example of a
substance that has a positive value for
delta h naught of solution is sodium
chloride
at 25 degrees celsius delta h naught of
solution for sodium chloride is positive
3.9 kilojoules per mole of reaction
an example of a substance that has a
negative value for delta h naught of
solution is magnesium chloride at 25
degrees celsius delta h naught of
solution for magnesium chloride is equal
to negative 160.0
kilojoules per mole of reaction the main
reason why these two substances have
such different enthalpies of solution
has to do with the third step so the
value of delta h3
so let's take a look at some diagrams
showing the ion dipole interaction of
the cation of both of these substances
in aqueous solution interacting with
water molecules for sodium chloride we
would have a sodium cation in solution
with a one plus charge
and for magnesium chloride it would be
an mg2 plus cation interacting with the
water molecules
because the mg2 plus cation has a higher
charge than the sodium cation and
because it's smaller the mg2 plus cation
exerts a greater electric force on the
water molecules
and because the magnesium two plus
cation exerts a greater electric force
on the water molecules more energy is
released when the magnesium two plus
cation is hydrated compared to when the
sodium one plus cation is hydrated
and since more energy is given off in
the third step for the hydration of the
magnesium two plus cation that's enough
to turn the overall delta h naught of
solution negative
therefore the dissolution of magnesium
chloride is an exothermic process
for sodium chloride when the sodium
cation is hydrated not as much energy is
released therefore the overall delta h
of solution is positive and the
dissolution of sodium chloride is an
endothermic process
next let's think about delta s naught of
solution delta s naught of solution is
equal to delta s1 plus delta s2 plus
delta s3 delta s1 the change in entropy
for the first step we saw was positive
delta s2 was also positive but delta s3
was negative therefore just like we saw
for delta h naught the sign for delta s
naught depends on the magnitude of delta
s1 plus delta s2 compared to delta s3 if
delta s1 plus delta s2 is greater in
magnitude than delta s3 delta s naught
of solution will be positive however if
the magnitude of delta s3 is greater
than the magnitude of delta s1 plus
delta s2 delta s naught of solution will
be negative
an example of a substance that has a
positive value for delta s naught of
solution is sodium chloride at 25
degrees celsius delta s naught of
solution is equal to positive 43.4
joules per kelvin mole of reaction an
example of a substance that has a
negative value for delta s naught of
solution is magnesium chloride at 25
degrees celsius delta s naught of
solution is equal to negative 114.7
joules per kelvin mole of reaction the
main reason for the difference in
entropies for these two substances has
to do with the third step so the
magnitude of delta s3 so once again
let's take a look at the diagrams
showing the hydration of the cations in
aqueous solution we've already talked
about the fact that the smaller and more
positive magnesium two plus cation has a
greater electric force on its
surrounding water molecules than the
sodium one plus cation does on its
surrounding water molecules the stronger
electric force means a decreased freedom
of movement of water molecules around
the magnesium two plus cation and a
decreased freedom of movement means a
decreased number of possible microstates
which means a greater decrease in
entropy
so the hydration of the magnesium two
plus cation leads to a greater decrease
in entropy for step three which
outweighs the positive values for steps
one and two and that gives an overall
negative value for delta s naught of
solution therefore dissolving magnesium
chloride in water results in a decrease
in entropy
since the sodium cation has a weaker
electrostatic attraction for water
molecules the decrease in entropy is not
as much and therefore the magnitude of
the third term does not overcome the
magnitude of the first two terms which
means the overall delta s naught of
solution is positive and dissolving
sodium chloride in water
results in an increase in entropy
we've just looked at delta h naught of
solution and delta s naught of solution
for two salts sodium chloride and
magnesium chloride let's calculate delta
g naught of solution for both salts at
25 degrees celsius
let's start with the dissolution of
solid sodium chloride and water to form
sodium cations and chloride anions 25
degrees celsius is 298 kelvin so we can
plug that into our equation and we can
also plug in the values for delta h
naught and delta s naught so both of
them were positive values for the
dissolution of sodium chloride
kelvin cancels out
and gives us delta g naught of solution
is equal to negative 9.0 kilojoules per
mole of reaction since delta g naught is
negative the dissolution of solid sodium
chloride
is a thermodynamically favorable process
which means at 25 degrees celsius sodium
chloride is soluble in water notice how
in this case the favorable positive
entropy term outweighs the unfavorable
positive enthalpy term to give a
negative value for delta g naught
therefore for the dissolution of sodium
chloride the increase in entropy drives
the dissolution
next let's do the same calculation for
the dissolution of solid magnesium
chloride in water to form the magnesium
two plus cation and two chloride anions
we've already seen how the increased
positive charge of the mg two plus
cation in solution gave us a negative
value for delta h naught and a negative
value for delta s naught so plugging in
all our numbers in a temperature of 298
kelvin kelvin cancels out and gives us
delta g naught of solution is equal to
negative 125.8 kilojoules per mole of
reaction since delta g naught of
solution is negative the dissolution of
magnesium chloride is a
thermodynamically favorable process
so at room temperature of 25 degrees
celsius magnesium chloride is soluble in
water however this time it's the
favorable negative value for the
enthalpy term that outweighs the
unfavorable negative value for the
entropy term to get to give a negative
value overall for delta g naught of
solution so this time it's the decrease
in enthalpy that drives the dissolution
delta g naught has been negative for
both sodium chloride and for magnesium
chloride however those are just the two
examples that i chose for this video
it's certainly possible to get a
positive value for delta g naught of
solution which would mean an insoluble
salt and because it can be very
difficult to predict the signs for delta
h naught and for delta s naught for a
particular salt it's even more difficult
to predict if delta g naught is positive
or negative for that particular salt
therefore it's often necessary to do a
calculation to see if delta g naught is
positive or negative